this was the last one D F T the hey
quick pause for puppy-sized elephant is
this heaven
wouldn't be a globe in heaven hey I'm in
some kind of fancy video studio so I
visit the studio where we will be
filming the Indianapolis episodes of our
new channel crash course I'm trying to
be a standee blogger but I'm just like
on some level not a standee blogger so
I'm gonna sit preferably in like a
really hideous shape perfect so many
because you know for a long time we've
dreamt of making an educational channel
on YouTube I just want to spin you like
a channel that would be both genuinely
informational and also genuinely
entertaining and now we finally have the
opportunity to do so we get to be
teachers so for 40 weeks beginning in
late January 2012 I'm gonna teach world
history and you are going to teach
biology which I'm really excited about
because I don't know anything about
biology and you're gonna make me more
smart and I appreciate smart smarter god
I am going to explain you in just 40
videos even you tuvalu obviously I think
it's gonna be like a very broad
introduction and then after we're done
we're going to start teaching other
courses literature chemistry physics
whatever you want us to do nerd fight
area we are so incredibly excited about
this take off topic but I feel kind of
like Tobuscus right now like make me
lighter make me lighter make me
handsomer there audience why does Hank
always sound like me when he does Hank
games I'm so bad at impression that
sounds nothing like Toby God love Toby
so much he's here isn't it but hey crash
course is only half the awesome news
because in early January you're
launching a channel called scishow which
is gonna be a show all about science
like science news but also answering the
age-old questions of science like why is
the sky blue the questions that Henry
asked me actually he hasn't asked me
those questions yet his major questions
are where did mommy go and more cupcake
question mark so they're links to
subscribe to crash course and scishow in
the doobly-doo and also here in Anna
please go there and subscribe we're so
excited about this I've said that seven
times but it's so true I know there are
giant squids of anger in comments right
now it's like vlogbrothers videos were
changing and that means hurt vide areas
gonna die but no blogg Brothers videos
aren't changing same Monday Wednesday
Friday schedule same you know crappy
shooting in our basement nothing is
changing nerdfighteria has been my home
town for a long time Hank and I am not
moving we're just trying to bring more
nerdy awesome stuff into the world with
you dftba Hank I will see you on
Wednesday